There is
a word called as kital meanings to kill
and Islam gives permission to do ketal
to go to war
whether it mean self-defense or at war
it is called asqar. So one type of jihad
is kal
that is war in self-defense or war when
required offense may be the best form of
defense.
So there is but as far as the word jihad
is concerned this word jihad in the
first half of the prophethhood of
Mhammed sallallahu alaihi wasallam when
Mhammed received the in about 23 years
for the first 11 12 years
first half of his prophethhood when he
lived in Makkah
many times the revelation of the Quran
were revealed in Makkah and the word
jihad that was used but the Muslims
in the Makkan period never did anymore
against a non-Muslim
that proved that jihad does not mean
killing or does not mean only going to
war here the jihad was used meaning to
strive and struggle many places for
example Allah says in the Quran in surah
and kabud chapter number 29 verse number
69 that if you strive and struggle if If
you do jihad in the path of Allah, Allah
will open up his pathways. Simple that.
If you strive and struggle, if you do
jihad, Allah will open up your pathway.
It doesn't talk about war.
Allah says in surah furan
chapter number 25
verse number 52
that do not
believe in the unbelievers
and strive strainously
against the unbeliever mean do jihad
against the kaf the unbelievers with the
Quran so how will you do jihad with the
Quran it doesn't say with the sword so
jihad with the Quran means we should
strive and struggle to explain the Quran
to the non-Muslims.
So surah furan chapter number 25:52
is telling the Muslims that strive
strainously
do excessive jihad with the non-Muslims
with the Quran that means you have to
explain the teachings of the Quran
strive and struggle to explain the
teachings of the Quran to the
non-Muslims in no way in no context does
it mean that they have to fight or you
have to wage a holy war it means to
strive and struggle
And one verse of the Quran is sufficient
to dispel this misconception about
jihad. Allah says in the Quran in surah
Maida chapter number 5 verse number 32,
if anyone kills any human being unless
it be for murder or for spreading
corruption in the land, it is as though
he has killed the whole of humanity. And
if anyone saves a single human being, it
is as though he has saved the whole
nation. Yeah. Allah is saying if any
human being whether Muslim or non-Muslim
kills any other innocent human being
whether Muslim or non Muslim it is as
though he has killed the whole of
humanity.
There is no verse in any other scripture
besides the Quran which says this. If
you kill a single innocent human being,
unless he has a murder or he has spread
corruption in the land, if you kill a
single innocent human being, it is as
though you have killed the whole of
humanity. And the verse continues, if
you save a single human being, whether
Muslim or non-Muslim,
if you save a single innocent human
being, whether Muslim or non-Muslim, it
is as though you have saved the whole of
humanity. What a verse.
This verse is sufficient to dispel any
misconceptions regarding jihad about
Islam
and
it is mainly the media
especially after 9/11
they are spreading misconceptions
regarding Islam
and today according to me media is the
most powerful
today media is the most powerful weapon
in the world. It can convert black into
white, day into night, hero into a
villain, villain into a hero.
Unfortunately, you Muslims are not
utilizing the media to convey the
message of Islam.
The non-Muslims are using this media to
attack Islam.
We should use this media to convey to do
dawa which is fur on every Muslim.